welcome to this video play JC yacht sajc
areas ok let's play one of my regular
openings be five okay so probably Scotch
no got a gambit IAM the danish gambit or
sometimes called Goering gambit it's a
very jacket sakutin not a very bitter a
quite unpopular line nowadays as black
easily equalizes with exactly the line
that i'm playing now here black has no
problems whatsoever I saw I'm not quite
sure a six or normal castles I think a
six then castling long
95 maybe hmm not quite sure you should
be six okay let's just play a lie good
strengthening movie
yo D 5 always have 95 or cams doing
something else entirely night coming to
g5 maybe and I'm just I'm just covering
that go on keep it simple because an ID
c5 I probably can just play 95
just blocking the Sun isolated pawn he
can try 96 rook d7 takes takes Knight g7
but that's not looking very young very
promising I think I came come on let's
get rid of this night and just play for
pawn structure he's got two bishops but
they don't do anything in this position
just blocked him yeah it is pawn
structure some totally am an influx i'm
flexible i cannot move any of the pawns
k no mighty IM activating attacking III
attacking edge form
that's quite nice already yeah but this
is the kind of last move that you want
to play okay now i have an excellent
position of course with a fantastic
night against this very bad bishop and
let's just activate here multiple ways
to get a good game or not get a good
games the wrong expression to UM and try
to realize your advantage not sure if I
should maybe put the knight on d5 it's
also good
hmm maybe the 95 possible quite unsure
on d5 it it blocks some everything very
nicely and maybe then I can prepare
furthered ones on the King side check
your Bishop f4 95 is not not looking any
good okay so g5 yeah why not g5g for
fixing on the on the light squares
g4 okay three rock evade this kind of
continuation I also wouldn't want to
exchange our roofs and then also would
be nice okay here threatening to to win
the ping pong on g3 yeah I could I could
take it now but then h 5 ER sir is
hanging unfortunately okay maybe you
just just increase a bit more 93 rook f2
is also a threat
you know I have time him no no use in
our pin in rushing anything k ever take
here this okay maybe I can can even
improve it further like that can I can
now grab a pawn hmm not bad but okay I
can still thinking I can still probably
improve I know I Shaq no I should take
come on this this is really you know
really easy now with the activated key
okay business isn't this is just a win
write it down should be a winning and
polite game or rookie too yeah that is
the easiest come it's not think any
longer here I get the default on white
forfeits due to disconnection okay
resigning us another way to do it yeah
it's just not a good opening I hate or
what God can use what can you say this
is probably about about equal with good
play but it it really am quickly went
went belly up for what something
something like that is just very
comfortable he has absolutely no palm
breaks here this is wrecked you have no
no a positive play
and it was a was easy to to to go from
here after he had taken on d5 with this
dead bishop and I was just trying to
improve slowly there were some ways to
play a maybe two to win quicker may be
here for example this is a good move
intending age find this Jeff is losing
big material there was some quicker ways
maybe but like and just improve this
very very slowly and win without any
risk like I did in the game alright
thanks for watching